by den tendrá la oportunidad de cumplir
una de sus promesas de campaña
el anuncio del retiro del liberal
stephen breyer le da la oportunidad al
mandatario de nominar la primera mujer
afroamericana a la corte suprema- la
casa blanca confirmó la intención del
presidente
number of a fire ha nominado una
cantidad histórica de jueces que son
personas de color pero la mayoría de los
jueces sean nominados son mujeres es
obra de su deseo y de su interés en
tener tribunales en todo el país que se
parezcan a eeuu incluidos los defensores
públicos y otros actualmente los
demócratas cuentan con una mayoría
simple en el senado para llenar la
vacante la corte suprema se compone de
nueve magistrados y en la actualidad
seis de ellos son de línea conservadora
después que el expresidente de donald
trump logrará confirmar a tres de ellos
durante su mandato muy recordado es el
caso de la fuerza liberal ruth báder
ginsburg quien falleció en 2020 poco
antes de las elecciones presidenciales y
fue reemplazada por emi con y barrett
breyer de 83 años estaba bajo presión
para acceder el carbón al aire
creo que vio que los demócratas no
podían sostener el senado por mucho más
tiempo y quería asegurarse de que su
legado estuviera en buenas manos
cada artículo de la jueza ruth báder
ginsburg suele mencionar que fue
reemplazada por alguien muy conservador
al hirschfeld weiss para esta one
entre las opcionadas estan leandra
kruger quien sirve en la corte suprema
de california y que tangi brawn
actualmente en el tribunal de
apelaciones de washington dice pero lo
que sí le abre oportunidades a una
comunidad afroamericana que a través de
la historia a unos 120 jueces de la
corte suprema
solamente han habido cinco mujeres que
han servido como jueces de la corte
suprema solamente dos afroamericanos en
toda su historia de cara a unas
elecciones de medio término en noviembre
en las que los demócratas corren el
riesgo de perder sus estrechas mayorías
en ambas cámaras del congreso el líder
de la mayoría oficialista del senado ya
anunció que la persona que nomine maiden
sería rápidamente confirmada